welcome inside Scotia Bank Arena exactly 1 month
ago the first game of the professional women's
hockey league was played in Toronto at the Old
Maple Le guards now Madame athletic center what
a day it was New Year's Day ring in a brand
new unified league for women's hockey record
attendance in Minnesota and Beyond the fans
coming out Millions watching that first game
and thousands more supporting in the week since
tonight the Canadian Tire pwhl 3on three showcase
gets going here the NHL allar [Applause] Thursday
working it for team King kin sends it back he has
Knight on the near side coin scoffield takes a
shot test smash Meer and a big save early on and
Kendall coin scoffield Knight and pulang a big
stretch pass and here's Laura sty she's got room
gets it front of DP what a save and Harmon two
de Partners from Clarkson University formerly
now there's a shot it's good Ella Shelton opens up
scoring for the pwhl a month ago does it tonight
here in the three on three showcase back to three
on three and again these minor penalties will be
served in one minute increments given L there's
a j Alex Carpenter rips that one no problem team
clth is on the board oh and Renee D knows that was
quite a mistake leading the league in points tied
with Alina Mueller and now Laura Stacy setting
up something here she was looking for that Fe
to Aaron Ambrose over to Mueller this time back to
pette she shoots it saved by Mash [Applause] Meer
Mash Meers had some big saves on pulen including a
penalty shot in the very first game p play coming
in fast fast with a drop pass to nurse nurse looks
to keep it nurse now feat Rockets up high here's
a big stretch pass and Lorac has room she shoots
she [Applause] scores what a shot I wondered if
she was looking back to see who she could pass to
to create a two on0 what a beautiful up pass look
she does a check where's the pressure who do I
have with me and what a [Music] shot now we go
back the other way Kelly Panic getting in close
shoot up high off the glass that time looking to
set something up has Alex Carpenter with her
no pass there gets in close and that skims by
they'll set it up again Alex Carpenter now in the
attacking Zone with Stacy shoots it oh with that
tip in Flair turn ball with a few great touches on
this shift Rumble sets it up again going to get on
the stick of pulen pulen has it talking about how
much and now Emily Clark gets in close and Daven
reads that one final seconds here in this first
fur in three on three showcase pen sets it up she
scores Savannah Harmon looks like she got
the tip in on that one but what an effort
to tie things up here the fans are loving it
as they should they want a play by Mari Philip
pulle picked up instead by coin
scoffield up to St line and it's red
by Nicole Hensley there is it off to rata
a fast fast to hey and in front that one
saved Hillary Knight shoots quick save there by
Hensley taking her time feel pretty confident
with the B right in front of a greasy wow that
could have been another Alex Carpenter
moment we saw that one earlier but player
as skilled as he standing right there on
top of the crease now Knight she'll test
it try to Hensley yeah just trying to
make sure she had it right behind her
captains of their respective pwhl teams cool
in looking for that feet to turn both sets up
Haron she [Applause] [Music] scores with a nice
read finds the puck knows exactly where Harman
is going to go for some movement get Franco
moving rock up and over what a move I love it
nice creativity Emily Clark for kendle points
SC field rather and in front of the net they
score there's the smiles everyone is talking
about Savannah Harman with a hatrick already
in this game her teammates are throwing their
gloves on the ice they may not to have the hats
to throw but uh showing their appreciation
St by Sarah nurse and now tlor heisy on a
breakaway she's going to go she shoots at Frankle
with the save heisy gets another chance though
she shoots once again all kinds of chances for
heisy fans Bon should got another shot off the
glass that time ends it back to Mueller Quick
Change there Far Side Play It Again think she
scores Kendall que scoffield he's racking up the
dally for team King players from the dolphin that
were part of the ceremony and again that one
well it's going to happen she said but right
now Hillary Knight has a breakaway in a Jaz
she shoots up High King swarming you've got
pulin and turnul out there Stacy here she's going
to drive it look what the pass she scores Brien
Jenner gets it done for team CL ticking
away Megan Duncan said there was time and
Aaron Ambrose up high final seconds here Brien
Jenner going to shoot hit the post there's the
ding and the loose clck rolls the buzzer sounds
and it's a definitive win for team King but just
a huge credit to these players and uh and the
show they put on here tonight for the Showcase
well done to the players I was going to say
we're going to need that video of that on ice